here's the exact quote he goes do you
want the numbers all right and in year
one we cleared 110 million dollars in
retail sales sorry 250 million in retail
sales and 110 million gross internally
[Music]
all right we're live what's up what's up
dude uh have you been following this
Prime energy drink thing or prime I
don't know what the [__] is it it's just
a Gatorade alternative right have you
filed it yeah I followed it because a
while back I don't know like a month ago
uh Ben business partner Ben he uh he
told me he met some guy who was like
involved with it he's like dude the
numbers are insane for Prime like
they're they're selling you know bleep
amount of just this one skew and like
let alone the main the main drink and I
was like there's no way uh that's a
crazy number and then I think recently
they came out and said
some more numbers yes what do they say
there's two takeaways here the first
takeaway is the numbers so Logan Paul
said the beverage brand he launched with
KSI uh on so on January 4th so about a
month or something ago he said it did
250 million in Revenue in the first year
and it did 44 million in Revenue in just
January of 2023 so recently
um and then he also said But then check
this out here's the exact quote he goes
do you want the numbers all right and in
year one we cleared 110 million dollars
in retail sales sorry 250 million in
retail sales and 110 million gross
internally so the takeaway here for me
is one that's huge numbers two what the
[__] does it what the hell does that
mean this guy doesn't even know his
numbers yeah
that could take away bro you're off by
half like uh that's crazy also what the
hell does 110 million gross internally
what he's saying is they sell Wholesales
so uh this because they sell this thing
let's say at Walmart so in Walmart it
did 250 million in sales but to them
they're they're getting bought at
wholesale prices so they the markup is
you know what what's you know they're
basically sell at Half Price Right so
they sell it to Walmart they sold 110
Million worth to Walmart so their
company sold 110 million the total
products sold 250 million as what I
think that has to mean well crazy crazy
that this is that big I've actually seen
a few interviews with Logan and uh he
says what the numbers are and then
someone from behind the scenes goes no
no it was this and he goes wait what oh
my bad it was this and it's pretty wild
that like I think Logan's a smart guy uh
I would love to have him on the Pod and
everything but it's pretty wild how he's
really just focused on the content thing
and probably doesn't know much about the
business thing it's pretty interesting
I've seen them like ask Mr Wonderful or
something about that about like
different stocks and things like that
and he's pretty has a pretty rudimentary
understanding of like certain Finance
topics that I thought for sure he would
be
somewhat on top of but I guess not you
can crush it without knowing that well
uh I don't know about that like I think
he I think he's like anything else like
the way we are probably good at business
oh and we're just enough to be dangerous
at the kind of like content you know
like you know like when we see a
YouTuber
both of us have had this reaction where
we're like oh we're horse carriage
operators and a Tesla just drove by like
this is when I see somebody on tick tock
you know you might as well be you know
it might as well be at Hogwarts with a
magic wand I'm like yeah like we're
doing something I don't know how to do
those things and I will never know and
like it's awesome but I I just can't
imagine myself really doing those things
at the level you can do them and so I
think he's good enough to be dangerous
on the business side and smart enough
obviously to know what categories to go
into and who to partner with so like if
you look at their moves right like just
zoom out so that you can't you know um
you know hear what he's saying or
whatever you look at their moves the
transition from Vine to YouTube great
jump the transition from YouTube
canceled to YouTube like you know
rejuvenated that's a good good move
there then from YouTube to boxing
celebrity boxing he ended up boxing
Floyd Mayweather and he did all right
all right yeah like and his brothers you
know doing he's one of the most you know
High earning uh you know boxers out
there maybe not a boxer yeah so that
that's incredible
um then the next jump you know for Logan
was WWE so now Logan is one of the big
stars in WWE but he does it on his terms
he then transitioned his YouTube content
into podcast context he's like you know
I'm maturing by the way have you seen
him in WWE he's really good he's really
good exactly like if I was 13 I pretty
sure I would think Logan Paul is the
[__] [__] because I'm 34 and I think
Logan Paul dudes the [__] [__] yeah
like he's good like he's got the acting
down he's got the uh he looks ripped
he's good
and people love to hate on these guys
um for you know good sometimes good
reasons they've done some things that
are like you know whatever he did this
the stupid video
um in Japan he's uh gets on he's got in
some trouble for his like nft thing but
like
I don't know I think there's a lot to be
to to learn from and admire in these
guys I'm not saying they're great people
perfect people I don't know them
personally I can't say either way on
that but I think from a marketing
perspective yeah they crush it 15 out of
10 right like from a brand building from
a sort of learning how to keep riding
new waves and stay relevant
um these I mean these are phenomenal the
same way that the Kardashians are
phenomenal in some way and you could
disparage them for a bunch of reasons or
you could look at the things they do
great and say cool I'm just going to
take inspiration from the things they do
great rather than hate on them in a very
common way about you know the same stuff
everybody else does
um so yeah I think you know what he's
done here is is pretty phenomenal I I
think they're kind of him and KSI are
kind of like
um minor Partners I think it's business
I think it's like a like a like a third
or third a third type of thing The
Operators get a third here yeah I mean I
I saw an interview and it was either a
third or like a 20 but uh yeah minority
but meaningful I mean this this can be a
billion dollar brand dude I invited him
to Camp MFM by the way and I was like
yeah you should come it's gonna be
awesome and he was like uh
he's like dude I can't get hurt this is
like I'm doing the WWE if I go play
basketball I'm gonna get hurt why did he
reply to you I can't like sprain an
ankle or twist the knee and like not be
able to go wrestle at WrestleMania in a
month what platform did you speak to him
on you know I actually what happened was
uh what had happened was that's what
happened was I jumped into Twitter
spaces where he was there and I just
started talking there
um and then he DM me afterwards and then
um I was like hey uh you know you
actually he had talked about my
Clubhouse or metaverse tweet on his
podcast too
um and I was like yo you actually talked
about my other thing you know that I'm
that guy and he was like oh cool
um
and so you know Twitter DM is kind of
where we talked dude that's actually
kind of a hack there's like a handful of
YouTubers that have five ten twenty
million subscribers who I've chatted
with on Twitter and they only have like
10 or 100 000 followers on Twitter and
they're fans children aren't using
Twitter and it's such a good way to like
get in front of them and uh I've
actually pulled that move a few times on
Twitter it's pretty pretty uh I'm
shocked it works that's genius
it's just not the same without thousands
of roaring fans chanting our name
signing you know people's backs and [__]
like that Harry backs uh very bad sweaty
backs you want to do a recap so
basically the gist of this is is Sean
and I did a somewhat impromptu
it was supposed to be a meet-up
uh turned into like a live performance
basically in Vancouver I don't know how
many people were there between a
thousand or 1300 ish but we sold out
this theater in Vancouver
it went pretty great uh you want to talk
about a few things that surprised you
yeah let's uh let's do that okay
surprising
um
surprisingly hard to be on stage even
though we kind of at this point talk for
a living
um there was a moment about an hour
before where we're both like like how do
you use your tongue do you touch it
against your teeth when you're making
sounds what do you do with that um and
we just had no idea what to say why did
it was like you know that moment of
panic where it's like are these people
even coming for us who are they is this
did they sell the tickets or did people
just click maybe like you know we just
questioned everything for a moment what
are we gonna say up front how do we make
this amazing for people
and uh there was really no thought that
went into this like one hour we went and
got sushi at a time and we were like so
what do you want to talk about we talked
about that for five minutes and then we
started talking to each other about
family and just fun stuff but yeah we
had like a 10 minute pow-wow to try to
figure it out but I think it turned out
okay either I think the content turned
down we we basically we're pretty tough
critics of ourselves I think we gave the
overall event an eight out of ten and I
think the
I think it was not it was not a 10
because I think it was a little poorly
structured like the opening part was a
lot of
intro Welcome to our spot thank our
sponsors that sort of thing and also we
weren't as well prepared as we could
have been in terms of like we could have
come up with things that that play
better live
than uh then on stage like I had the
Moment of clarity afterwards I was like
oh it's a show that's live with the
audience we should be doing things like
a b and c yeah yeah um and we didn't
fully get that but we did like a little
shark tank pitch competition we did q a
we did some stuff with the crowd dude I
think that was good all things
considered I thought it was actually a
nine I think like given the amount of
preparation and the amount of fun people
had uh another shocking thing was people
came I think the value in order was to
see us to meet one another than to
actually hear what we had to say yeah
right right exactly and I think there's
some benefit in doing it in Vancouver
where there's probably just not a lot of
events going on for entrepreneurs OR
tech people that are like exciting uh
versus I think if we had done this in
San Francisco we probably would have got
more numbers but they wouldn't have
cared as much like there was a lot of
people at this thing in Vancouver that
traveled from Toronto or from Portland
OR from different places to come see it
because oh might as well it's a couple
hours away and uh you know
it you know there's not going to be
another thing like this anytime soon
where I'm at
um so anyways those were some quick uh
quick Recaps I guess if people weren't
there what should we explain what did we
actually do so it was me you and Andrew
Wilkinson on stage it was in this
theater so there's like a balcony
seating there was like a you know
basically a giant theater where like a
comedian would normally play in fact
backstage as we're walking up it was
truly humbling and I mean humbling in
the in the most [__] on myself way which
was we were walking up to the stage and
it's like these framed pictures of guys
who were in that stain same green room
before us it's like Jerry Seinfeld Dave
Chappelle it's like all these like
legendary comedians it's like some of
the best podcasters that you've ever
seen in the entrepreneurship category on
Apple podcast
it was humbling another thing that was
humbling was after it happened we left
the stage and we went and just hung out
with people and there was this a huge
line and what it made me realize was
that so a lot of people don't realize
this but it's basically Sean and me and
producer Ben Jonathan sometimes and we
are sitting here just recording talking
to each other you forget all we forget
on a regular basis that it's being
recorded when the podcast gets published
we don't see comments we don't know like
we could see the numbers but it's just
like an analytics screen I don't know
who's listening why they're listening I
don't know any of that and so you forget
that this stuff actually
kind of matters to some people and it's
really fun to go and meet people who
consume your thing and realize wow this
actually matters to them that was
humbling as well and then there would be
like a father and son be like we always
listen to the Pod together and then we
brainstorm he's 14 but he wants to be an
entrepreneur like you guys so after we
listen to the Pod we then brainstorm and
do stuff it's like oh that's really cool
this is like a it's like embedded in
your kind of like family a little bit
you know there were examples like that
that were very surprising to me but but
cool also I should say you were good at
that like you were really good on stage
Sam was I don't know what happened I
think the nicotine pouch kicked in and
Sam went to another level I'm gonna
start doing nicotine dude that was a
great ad for for that uh Sam had great
jokes and then afterwards also I feel
like in the meet and greet you were good
at being kind of the celebrity like I
didn't know what to do with my hands you
know people would come up be like can I
take a picture and my response was like
why oh yeah sure I guess and then they
would stand next to me and I would do
this like Point thing to each one of
them like this guy like if you look go
look on the Instagram every picture with
me I'm just doing nah it's about this
guy right here
and you were giving them the billionaire
hug which um I don't know if people
picked up on but you you taught me this
afterwards I didn't know this trick
explain the billionaire hug so I have a
theory that once you hit a billion
dollars you get like invited to this
like seminar and they teach you how to
do a billy hug which is basically when
you hug someone your hips and ass are in
One Direction but then your shoulders
and arm lean hard to the right and so
you could be touching them shoulder to
shoulder but ask to ask you're never
touching them and this is like a way to
like look we're touching and I'm being
affectionate but like my crotch isn't in
the vicinity therefore it's safe it's
all good this is PC and so I do the
billiona hook I also bring my wife along
to all these things as well because it
always freaks me out I'm like I don't
know man I don't want ever I don't want
anyone to get the wrong idea sometimes
you know it's just it's just it can be
uncomfortable every once in a while so I
did the Billy hug I do that I'm not a
billy but I did the Billy hug because I
is it a is it a sexual thing is it like
you know you're you're keeping your
wallet away from them what are you doing
why does the why do the hips need to be
away is there even an explanation or is
just something that only billionaires
would understand it's just a
time-honored tradition I don't know I'm
not there yet so I don't know but I just
I you know it's like singing in the
shower I copy my heroes uh so that's why
I do it um and this is a man and a woman
thing by the way it's from the men as
well I've noticed that sometimes we have
this relationship with people where they
hear us talk and they think oh you're so
approachable and sometimes they'll come
up to me and they'll go dude let's [__]
let's do this and I'm like whoa you're
coming on too hard to me I know I say
this stuff but you're coming on too hard
so sometimes you need to set some
boundaries and that's my mini boundary
it's the crotch boundary right
uh we we so we had our buddy Andrew on
there Andrew was really funny too I
gotta say Andrew who's been on the Pod a
bunch of times I've never met in person
so I've talked to him on the phone we've
done Zoom calls he's come on the Pod but
in person I gotta say he's got a lot
more juice than I expected and to tell
the story about dinner or lunch
so we go to lunch so before the show
we're like oh dude we gotta hang out man
you're he's kind of from this area I
thought Vancouver BC is all the same
thing actually you got to take
a seaplane yeah or a helicopter so he
took a [__] Chopper to come beat us
which is honestly one of the more big
dog moves anyone's ever done to me
um well the reason we knew it was a big
dog move because he was a little he was
like five or ten minutes late and
instead of saying uh you know my flight
was delayed he said I was late for my
flight
and I was like wait what yeah
that's subtle I didn't pick that up I
just heard over what he called on the
phone it was just
I just heard the chopper going and I was
like hey wait a minute is there a fan on
near you what's going what is that
um so he lands and before he lands he
goes I'm gonna be five to ten minutes
late again I was late for my flight and
then he goes um just order me Eddie on
that list this order to me and Sammy
goes
eight oysters two two seven nigiri this
like you know whatever Wagyu steak
um you know a miso soup I have a nut and
a shellfish allergy I'll die if somebody
does that and then he just signs It Off
thanks but just THX and
I see this I'm I was I was running late
too as as per usual I was in the shower
at this point I just started laughing
Sam replies what did you say
I was like did you just say thanks to me
like yes sir I mean it was like
ridiculous and he was like sorry he
tried to blame an autocorrect we're like
nah bro you're just used to talking to
people too much like that you you have
people who let you get away with that
that [__] might fly in Canada but you
don't bring that weak THX [__] too yeah
to the United States of America we we
reject that we send that back
we go to lunch
and we're having a good time we're just
catching up again Andrew's got the juice
he's got the juice in the way that my
best friends who I look up to the most
have that juice you have that too when
you hang out in person with Sam
he's got a little bounce in his step and
it just seems like he's eager he's
excited he's got a plan wherever you go
there's not gonna be it's not gonna just
be a default normal experience something
a little more fun is going to happen
something a little extra is going to
happen a little more laughter a little
more
um you know learning something extra is
going to happen so Andrew had that which
I was uh which was awesome to see
because he's quite I don't know would
you say like reserved or calm he's got
almost like a calm brand but in person
his energy was a lot more kinetic
freewheeling and I liked it he had a
very kinetic energy where he was
physical you know he was moving yeah it
was that's a great way of putting it
yeah he was kinetic he had that and I
have that too people always yell at me
because I've got big thighs and I shake
and whenever I shake my thighs the table
moves and they're like dude you're too
kinetic so yeah he's got that kinetic
energy and we're having this wonderful
lunch it's probably an hour and a half
in and then we're not quite done eating
yet or at least it doesn't feel there
and then all of a sudden he goes oh
shoot and we're like What like he like
it's like a panic he goes dude my Uber's
been outside waiting for me for 10
minutes I gotta go bye and he just
stands up and walks away and we're like
you know he was even better than that he
just stood up like he was stretching for
a second
and then he picked up his jacket and
he's like I'll see you guys at the place
we're like what and he goes yeah sorry I
gotta go my Uber's been outside for 10
minutes when did you call an Uber
and he floated away like a balloon like
he was the grandfather and up and he
just went away the house flew away and
then me and Sam were like okay
yo was that weird that he just kind of
floated away like a balloon yeah it's
like we'll work on conversation skills
later Andrew have a nice day yeah you
just kind of Bounce
um I had to blow him a kiss
so far it's the only appropriate goodbye
but in general the thing was awesome now
I I don't I'm not gonna put you on the
spot but I would like us to do a five or
three like thing where like a day thing
where we could do like you know three
dates in five days I want to go to like
C and B cities so not the New Yorks not
the SFS something like uh Denver or
Toronto or Kansas City something where
they're you know what what did you call
it small pish small pond syndrome that's
what I want to be I want to be a a big
fish in a small pond because these
people were piss in a small phone
can you um
uh you have a little something on your
shirt here I think you got a little
taste of Fame a little dribble of that
Fame that just stained the shirt there
you you like that taste of Fame didn't
you well here's why I like it
we've talked about we know why you like
it yeah because being famous is awesome
it is awesome but it is exhausting now I
understand why like the touring bands
who last a long time they show up they
do the concert and they go home and go
to bed I was like I couldn't sleep
because we were like did we hung out
with everyone then we had like a
breakfast the next day but anyway I
liked it because it was a challenge I
also think that in our little Tech world
we assume that we're this little niche
internet nerds which we are but it's
actually cool to like Flex and see the
people and and honestly felt like a
movement and there was times where I I
felt
it was you and I were great at what we
do but in reality we were just an excuse
and like a steward of like a particular
type of movement of these people who are
like you know we're all on a journey
some people are further ahead some
people are uh not there yet some people
don't want to go far some do but they're
all going someplace and it felt like we
were just an ex an excuse to gather
those people and it really felt Beyond
and bigger than us I know that sounds
woo-woo and [__] like that but that's
truly how it felt and so that's why I
thought it was cool
I agree 100 percent
At first I felt so excited I was like
man I can't believe we sold out this
theater there's 2 000 people on the
waitlist they came to see us and I think
there was a a small part that was like
oh that's like the stated excuse but the
reality is that the value was just
if you like this podcast that's put you
through a bunch of filters and the
filters are like
a lot of our of our sayings right so
it's like you know no small boy stuff
right so it's like people who want to
think big for themselves but they Define
what big means for them but it's also
people who don't take themselves too
seriously if you want the smartest
podcast you should go listen to invest
like the best and go listen to all in
and go listen to a bunch of podcasts
with people who are
their intellectual horsepower outruns
ours right the oven Burns a little
hotter for those guys than it does for
us
um if you want somebody who like we will
celebrate a dude who's like a plumber
that's hacking the Yellow Pages to get
more leads as much as we will a guy
who's building a new a new city or a new
country you know from scratch and so
there's like this set of people who
appreciate the same things we appreciate
and when you put them together we're
probably like it's not easy for them I
think of their day-to-day life to be
around a bunch of other people who are
like them the sort of schemer and
dreamer
um you know uh a profile or archetype
and so that's what I saw was the best
because I was like oh man sorry you guys
had to wait they're like no it was
awesome I was in line with a bunch of
other people who I met this guy who's
doing this and this guy who's doing this
and I said oh wow okay that makes sense
to me like the real value here wasn't
coming and getting a selfie with me as I
do my awkward point it was actually just
getting like to be in a community of
other people who have that who have the
same sort of freak energy that you have
and um then once that once I saw that I
was like okay this makes sense we should
do you know more of this dude I met a
guy like there was a couple billionaires
in the crowd I don't know if you know
that and I'm not going to call them out
but I I met one of them
um or at least their their stake and
they they own multiple they have large
steaks and multi-billion dollar
companies and I remember I met one of
them and he was like a typical like
dorky guy and then I met this other guy
who had a sheetrock business that like
you know it's like a blue collar thing
and his hands were just so meaty and fat
and I remember shaking his head that I
told him I was like dude I can't even
wrap my hand around your hand and I'm
not small and uh that's and I was like
dude that's sick we got we got the neck
beards they had the callous hands guys
and uh and this guy one of the guys I go
yeah just you know DM me on Twitter he
goes okay cool you'll see me my Twitter
handle is called [__] manly and uh
that's what he said to me and I was like
all right that's badass a hat yeah he
he's uh he said something he's like my
wife has a big Instagram following for
women's stuff so I decided to create
[__] manly to to like counteract that
that was awesome
um I want to tell you about one woman
who I thought uh was really had a really
I know her well it came out I know her
well so I was at the there was a dinner
the night before that the tiny guys
hosted and at the dinner met some people
whatever was good uh one woman came up
and she goes um
she's like hey my name's uh Anya you
know a big fan of and then she gave me a
hot little like quick high five she goes
I just made my first million and I was
like nice uh what do you do and um and
she was like well
you know we I created this app for
people with panic attacks it's called
rooted and I was like panic attacks is
that like you an app for panic attack I
never would have even thought about that
Niche and uh she's like yeah you know I
struggled with it like crazy
um and so then I created this app so she
pulls out this app called rooted and
rooted as in like you know feeling
grounded instead of having you know this
sort of panic attack and there's like a
red panic button you can hit if you're
feeling something in the moment but
there's also just like sleep there's
like lessons where you can learn about
like what is this thing and why does
this happen like drills and breathing
exercises exercise breathing exercises
and so on and so forth and she said she
has had
two point something million downloads of
this app and I thought okay that's
pretty great um that's not even the
crazy part
then I was like wow um are you are you
just really good at Facebook ads or what
she goes no I don't do any paid
marketing yeah and I was like so how do
you get two point something million
downloads off this she goes well um I
think you know it's all a real problem
and also I dominate like the App Store
search for this because everybody else
went really broad they tried to go for
like sleep or anxiety or breathing and I
went for panic attack because everybody
else thought that was too narrow and I
just really like did a good job owning
that in the App Store ASO right instead
of SEO the App Store optimization and
then I started getting good reviews and
it just snowballed and now I'm like the
top one in that and I thought did she
tell you how big the team was
exactly so I was like
um I was like she's already halfway to
being my hero at this point and I go and
this is her first deal this is our first
time I gotta seal the deal for me uh how
big is your team she goes it's just me
yeah crazy right I go what and she goes
yeah it's just me I have a couple
contractors that you know help me with
things but there's no employees I don't
want any employees
um and I was like I want to be you
you're you know you're she's building
something that has an impact
um you know she dominated it her way
when anybody else would have like if she
went to go ask you know smart guys like
us or you know ego ask a mentor what
should I do they'd either say you know
go ask an investor they'll say it's too
small of a market go ask a mentor
they'll say well you need to you know
what's your growth strategy and she's
like I don't know I just want to build a
useful product and like I'll figure it
out as I go third is like you need to
scale up no way because she's closing
these deals now with like health care
companies where they'll just provide it
for like you know all of the members of
their gold plan so like they'll pay for
it for 50 000 members or something like
that now and
Ellie do you need a BD rep and a sales
team and all the stuff she's like no I
just go take the meeting myself and it
took some time but we got the dealership
she said she meets them on LinkedIn she
goes I just message them on LinkedIn
fantastic so I thought uh Anya you know
shout out to her she's the she's got the
I don't know not Billy of the week not
blue collar side hustle she's something
else but like you know the riches and
niches Award of the week um you know it
goes to her because I thought that was a
pretty amazing story no it was amazing
and this is her first business and so
like you know everything that she said
or everything that she has done if you
told me like if she told me the idea
which is uh I'm gonna I've never done
anything Tech related before and I can't
code I'm gonna hire contractors overseas
to do this I don't know anything about
marketing I'm like oh you're everything
you're saying you're gonna lose this
won't work right and she completely has
pulled it off and if you if you go to
the reviews did you look up her app I
mean it's legit like there's like uh I
think it's like a 4.9 rating it's like a
really high rating thousands of reviews
and she completely has pulled it off I'm
almost positive it's only two-ish years
old like it's not it's not it's not uh
right and then she also just went full
time as of recently so this was like and
I just started monetizing I think it's
like most of the app is free she's like
yeah I want most of the app to be free
um you know because obviously I'm trying
to help as many people as I can I'm
trying to find that balance uh where
it's a sustainable business but also
most of the app's free and uh I just
thought that was a bad badass story
there was a bunch of people there that
had like really big stories but to me
that was a a really I just say
incredible and incredible win and she
had a kind of a
and intensity about her oh yeah you
could almost tell when you were talking
to her like okay even though on paper
you got no attributes right and we all
know the rule you gotta have some
attributes if you want to win she didn't
have the experience she didn't have the
skill of certain things but she did have
a certain level of intensity and you
could see that uh just in talking to her
like her just the way she came across
she came across like a person to be
taken seriously and like she was like a
like a very small person it wasn't like
her stature but she didn't have a
natural Knack at that it was just the
way she was talking that that stood out
to me did you uh did you meet the Vesti
guy so v-e-s-s-i yeah we went out for
lunch so
um I I don't know if I can say what what
they do I don't maybe you could say but
if they told you the number I'm not
gonna say any numbers but uh
Tony was the the guy who's there is the
founder and they make awesome shoes
apparently I haven't tried them so I
can't do that but they're hardcore in
Vancouver and so I um my the lady at my
hotel saw me uh wearing them and she
goes oh you're wearing vessies those are
those are happening so basically this
shouldn't say they're happening because
she's not 60 years old uh but you know
she said they're cool those are Jazzy
friends
uh but anyway so it's this shoe called
vesi they look just like tennis shoes
but apparently they're like waterproof
which is a big deal in Vancouver because
it rains a lot and it's wet and the guy
bootstrapped the bootstrapped the
company and he told me the top line
revenue which I don't know if we could
say or not just say it and we'll bleep
it uh oh okay fine we'll say say it and
bleep it but over
um and so basically you you guys didn't
hear what I just said but we're talking
like not we're talking in the same
ballpark of like an all birds or
something like that like a publicly
traded company uh quite huge completely
bootstrapped and I started talking to
him and he's like hey um I I want us
like I'm thinking about like getting
popular on Twitter and then he started
talking to me and I start giving
feedback and then he told me about the
company and I and he told me the size
and I'm like wait wait
why do you want to be on Twitter you
realize this is totally not worth your
time and you are like way better than
any of the thread boys including me
don't go on Twitter dude just keep
crushing it and the company that he had
was entirely bootstrapped and it started
as a Kickstarter so he was like I was
like why are you guys so good he said
negative cash flow like uh negative cash
cycle which means um
you know people sell the stuff before
they have to pay for the goods yeah he's
like we just have good terms with a with
a manufacturer and we started as a
Kickstarter so it's been profitable
since day one and and this is another
thing where it breaks all types of uh
patterns that I thought possible so
starting in Vancouver Vancouver's not a
big city I think the metropolitan area
is like 800 000 or sorry the
metropolitan area is 2 million the city
is only 800 000 so it's not like an
episode I went for a run and I like ran
across the city and I don't run so it's
not the thing yeah and it's like not
that big of a city it's in Canada which
I didn't realize how like
Canada's kind of Podunk like it's it's a
it's like it's like it's like there's
only like 30 million people in that
whole place it's like Canada has the
same population as California it's crazy
in the same population as like the
Metropolitan New York area I mean it's
right but the size of that it's bigger
than the United States in terms of like
the actual land mass so it's like just
it's a lot of empty space or a lot of
space per person yeah like it's not that
big and uh it's a little behind in terms
of like it's not like a sophisticated
place a decision isn't bad but like I
remember I went to the airport and they
checked my passport in such an odd
location and like I remember they
checked it like as I was going through
the security thing to like scan my my
body not ahead of time I'm like oh you
guys know it would be way faster if you
do this this uh whatever uh and so
anyway I met this guy and his company
kills it and so he uh huge company in
Vancouver dominated Vancouver they love
the shoes there everyone was talking
about it incredibly quiet and nice no
like they opened up they opened up a
physical store in Vancouver
of that yeah the video of the line
there's like a line like
and I was like yes you like is this I'm
like a marketing stunt you like paid
people to stand in this line he's like
no these are like actual customers no
he's like it's Monday leave this too but
he said they're gonna do out of their
retail location this year I was like
what the hell that's an absurd number
it's crazy this guy was really really
cool uh so I'm happy I got to meet him
um but anyway good weekend we had a good
time we'll do it again
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better you want to
talk about uh you have another topic or
you want me to go uh I got one and then
uh but Let's do let's do okay let's do
this one first so we went International
we went um abroad some might say some
might say offshore you know they'd be
wrong but if you could say offshore they
got me thinking about it sure companies
offshoring money and like I don't know
about you but I've always heard about
this but if you had ever asked me to
explain
yeah wait how do companies like offshore
what is what's a tax Haven like how do
these things work do you actually know
how this [__] works because no I went
down a random Rabbit Hole last night and
pretty interesting stuff dude I have no
idea I don't even know really how this
actually works I don't know what it
means but I like using it uh you know
what I'm saying like I don't know I
don't really want one yeah yeah yeah
yeah like it's it's right under uh shell
shell Corporation when people think
about well actually they're related all
right so so here's the kind of the
headline or the takeaway which is that
companies like Nike Apple huge companies
right the companies that we've all heard
of use this this is not just like oh I
don't know Shady crypto guys that are
opening up a company in the Bahamas or
whatever it's like you know the most
Blue Chip of Blue Chip companies Apple
at one point had like 300 billion
dollars offshore overseas that they
weren't bringing back into America why
because the here's the general like
first principles explanation so you uh
every country has a tax rate so let's
say in in the United States the
corporate tax rate let's say is 21 well
if you make money here you're gonna pay
21 on all your profits but if you're
able to shift those profits so that they
are taken in another country you can use
that country's tax rate well guess what
there are several countries that have a
tax rate of pretty much zero and so what
these companies do is like I'll give you
an example of Nike so Nike did This
brilliant thing that resulted in Nike
paying like I don't know something like
three percent a year tax rate on
billions and billions of dollars of uh
of Revenue and profits and so how did
they do this well what they did
initially was was
they created a shell company there we go
Bingo uh shell company in Bermuda and
the shell company in Bermuda owned the
swoosh like the trademark to the Nike
check and then what happened is company
in the United States is selling shoes
but then and it might rack up let's say
10 billion dollars of Revenue uh or even
like gross gross profit so like you know
after taking out into account the shoes
and the shipping and all that
Well normally they just have to pay the
tax on the 10 billion well what they
would do is
the swoosh company in Bermuda would then
charge them 9 billion let's say
um in royalty payments saying hey you're
using the swoosh you got to pay us for
that so all of a sudden the taxable
income in the US goes from 10 down to
one and now they just pay the 20 on the
1 billion and the 9 billion that the
Bermuda company got pays a tax rate of
zero right so their effective tax rate
goes way way down and so this is what
they did initially and then um and this
lasted for like you know some period of
time
um but then and then they kind of close
these loopholes over time so Nike had
this had this setup in in the
Netherlands and they had this set up in
the Netherlands where uh they had you
know some Nike international company
over there they were doing this where in
the Netherlands they didn't have to pay
taxes on on the money for some period of
time because there was like a rule where
on royalty income you don't have to pay
taxes so they're like great all the
revenue this company's making is the
royalty income from the IP the the
swoosh trademark that were
um that were trademark were renting out
basically to our other companies and so
they were not paying any taxes on your
Middle East whatever
and then what happens is
um you know after 10 years people start
complaining they closed that loophole
the politicians high five they're like
we did it these big corporations are
going to pay their fair share
and Nike goes oh hold on let me uh
to get the Blackberry out
they call they call up the lawyer they
say hey uh one whole closed open up
another police
hang up the phone and that the lawyers
get to work and they realize we could do
something different here's what we'll do
we'll create two Dutch companies and one
of them will have a director in the
United States because here's what
happens in the United States the law
says if your company if the company is
incorporated somewhere else it should be
taxed in that country
and then the Netherlands it says well if
it has U.S directors it's going to be
taxed in the U.S so it's kind of like
those like goofy those movies where like
the two guys are pointing he's got it no
he's got it wait what nobody's been
taxing this thing and so they they had
what was called a stateless company a
company that was taxed nowhere which is
called Nike innovate CV and uh it paid
zero taxes basically and so companies
like Nike have been able to do this
um Apple does the same thing Facebook
does the same thing I don't know if
you've ever seen like why all these tech
companies have offices in Ireland and
Dublin everyone has a Dublin I was like
wow you know okay is it the Great is it
the the Fantastic world-renowned
engineering Talent of Dublin what what
is the reason for this and the reason is
because there was something called the
double Irish strategy which said if you
have one one Irish company that owned
the IP and then another one that was uh
you know just like a subsidiary of it
and then that one had U.S director same
thing zero Taxation and so for for five
years I think Apple made 30 billion
dollars through their Irish companies
and paid zero taxes on it and I just
think this is are you gonna do this how
they do this stuff and by the way Tim
Cook goes and he says he stands in front
of Congress there's this amazing clamper
he goes apple pays every dollar that
they owe in taxes
um we don't depend on tax gimmicks we
don't stash money in some Caribbean
island it's like yeah you Statute in
Ireland instead like what are you
talking about here
um and then like you know they've kind
of shut that double Irish strategy down
and then the uh and then Apple goes and
this is all this all got leaked from
this thing that you probably remember
called do you remember like the Panama
papers yeah yeah that got leaked yeah do
you know what actually happened there uh
a bunch of
cut they uh Panama was a city or a
country sorry a country where this
happened and I don't know how it got
leaked I think the accounting firm that
did a lot of the work for people got
hacked exactly the fourth biggest Law
Firm was something called mozak Fonseca
and basically this is the fourth often
they're known for like creating shell
companies and all this stuff
they got hacked or so not hacked
actually somebody just leaked 11 million
documents oh my god um they don't know
who leaked it but somebody was like a
whistleblower leaked this thing and
there's like this this team of
journalists that looked at it for a year
before finally going forward and
Publishing the Panama papers well after
that there was something called and
that's where like the sort of Epstein
and Putin stuff came out of the the
Panama papers then there was the
paradise papers which came after that
and that was leaked from this accounting
firm called Applebee and um you know and
it's an interesting name you're familiar
you're in your client of theirs yeah
is there a is there a like a Hooters LLC
that can handle my income tax like yeah
these guys do shell companies and soft
shells tacos
we like all types of shells shell
macaroni and shell companies
exactly so so you know they basically
they got leaked two and then that's when
the the company stuff that came out uh
came out as far as and then you could
see Apple going to their Law Firm they
leaked the email saying
um we we've you know the Irish thing is
coming to an end we'd like to find
another country that has this favorable
Advantage can you find us something in
the you know maybe in the Caribbean like
dude pretty much the exact opposite
thing as he said in front of uh Congress
you did something that I think is funny
and um so basically when people discuss
these topics they use all type of all
types of words that in itself are not
like by definition are not bad words and
they actually don't mean bad things but
they use it in this context and people
automatically think villain and
sometimes I find myself using those
words on purpose but like bragging about
them so for example loophole uh you use
the word loophole why don't we just call
it a rule you know like we're just
following the rule this is the rule
we're gonna we're gonna use the rule
they use loophole loopholes aren't bad
just the rule another one manipulate why
don't we just use like persuade or
influence and so like people use that
word manipulate all the time another one
is exploit I love that word exploit I'm
like oh so to efficiently use something
like people talk about Amazon is
exploiting their workers I'm like what
does that mean is that the point is we
give you money and then we exploit you
like we I myself okay cancel okay cancel
Sam well we just got famous bro don't
don't ruin this well they use these
words and I'm like that word like that's
that's the point is to exploit we're
going to use this in a very particular
way and we're going to use it
efficiently and you did you just did
that where you use these words but it's
like you're saying the word loophole as
if it's a scam where it's like no
loophole's the opposite of a scam it's
right this is we are playing in the
rules uh well I think that they do mean
something which is that they're within
the rules but not the they're within the
letter of the law but not the Spirit of
the law and I think that's the the
that's the don't get all pro bono lawyer
on me bro
there's Bros science now you're doing
bro legal jargon
by the way Tim Cook actually even said
that too in that same clip he goes we
not only comply with the letter of the
law but a spirit of the law too which
was you know that's a lie
um but yeah I think you're right which
is
There are rules of the game and
you can play if you play by those rules
you should not blame the player you
should hate the rule maker right you
should hate the game
um
and so I think that that's that's where
a lot of people go wrong right they hear
this stuff when I'm explaining these I'm
not saying apple and Nike are evil
really what I'm saying is I never really
knew what this meant I never knew
actually how it worked dude you're a
capital you're a capital J journalist
you're just saying the facts I'm a
capital man I think we established that
myself
um so so yeah I think this is kind of
interesting and then it's like what's
the game theory so one thing that Trump
did which is actually pretty smart which
is another loaded thing you can't say
um was he was like dude these companies
have like hundreds of billions of
dollars overseas because what happens is
once they get taxed in the low low tax
place they can't just move the money
back into their you know Chase Bank here
in America and like you know go go down
to the ATM and pull it out like it would
get taxed when it comes back so they
leave it overseas
um
so this is money that never reaches and
so what Trump did was he goes all right
look I'm going to make a one-time
exception for you to What's called
repatriate the cash bring the cash back
to America I'll lower the tax rate it's
like kind of like all right guys get in
here kind of like you know the store
owner like opens the back doors like get
in it's like a five minutes it's like a
gun give back you ever seen those where
you can like no questions asked just
give us your guns right right exactly
and I think there's some some value to
those the scenarios
um and so he made it like you know it's
15 tax on that cash this is like one
time one time only if you want the cash
back in America so you can invest it
here and use it in your corporate
activities here you know here's your
your sort of like discount half price
um okay come on in and uh and that
brought like I don't know 60 or 90
billion back in but but not like the
full amount he thought four trillion
would come back in and it they just
didn't speaking of uh crazy people and
huge men in terms of size and loopholes
and tax evasion I've got a cruel story
for you and I have a feeling you know
about this person this is this is the I
don't know if he's a billy but he's he's
close enough have you heard of tim.com
you know who this guy is yeah yeah he's
he's prolific as you like to say dude
this guy that's the phrase here I was
gonna say this guy's a prolific freak
he's a total freak so this guy named
kim.com has all these interesting facts
and I read about him because he
he's like six seven 350 pounds this
guy's massive he's huge and he lives in
New Zealand and he uh him and his wife
he married like a Philippine like beauty
queen or something like that and she
divorced him and and these people
thought that they were gonna like she
was gonna talk [__] about him she's like
no no like I have nothing bad to say
about him it just it the marriage didn't
work out but he was a nice guy uh and so
I started reading about him by the way
what's his real name uh it's so Kim
Schmitz but then he was known as Kim Tim
Jim Vester or Kimball and then
eventually he legally changed his name
to uh.com so the wife the ex-wife kept
her married last name and her name is
like you know like sarah.com and so like
the article refers to her as like
miss.com uh it's like so that's her
legal name so this guy is like I'm gonna
become Sean worldwide Mr worldwide this
is my wife this is worldwide nice to
meet you dude critical referred to as
miss.com and so check this out so this
guy
in the 90s he starts in Germany as a
hacker and he hacks something like 40
million or he claims this but this is
not verified he said he uh hacked into
some like famous bank and he took 40
million dollars and he donated it to
Greenpeace at least that's what he said
but TBD if that's actually true because
Greenpeace is like no that's not true
and then eventually he starts building
all these other programs and all this
like software that is like mildly
successful and he tries to set and he's
a hacker all while he's doing this doing
a bunch of illegal [__] but while doing
this he's trying to send a file to his
friend and the email that he's trying to
send it through says all right you've
exceeded the limit we can't do this so
he creates this thing called mega upload
which eventually like gets huge have you
heard of mega upload if you ever
download a an illegal movie or anything
like that you've probably come across
mega upload have you
of course yeah never never used it for
textbooks but uh definitely have used
Mega uploaded live yeah so mega upload
it's kind of like Napster but you don't
need a DOT I don't think you uh it's
just a website so you don't need to
download a client so it's um like Pirate
Bay I guess is a similar one but again
you still don't need a client it's just
a website where you can like trade files
and it goes viral because all these
people would share files and he would
put like mega upload like in the uh like
image so like that's how it like Groove
uh and got viral and so anyway he
creates this thing and it swells he
launches it in 2005 and in 2010 he's
basically he's able to pay himself 42
million dollars that was his personal uh
income from that and eventually after
like eight years he gets sued and
Hollywood sues him I guess I don't know
what Hollywood is but big Hollywood sues
him uh the government sues the sign yeah
the sign and they say that he uh made
close to 200 million dollars in personal
profit from this whole thing and all
during this he's doing like this other
crazy [__] so out of like 50 million
Modern Warfare uh players this guy was
ranked number one he was the number one
player for Call of Duty yes in 2012 he
was the number one person in the world
at Call of Duty he also finished first
in the Gumball 3000 you know what that
is it's like a race it's a car race
across Europe he finishes first then he
releases an album of original music with
any like collabs with other articles uh
other artists it's called good times and
it's not that bad uh of an album to be
honest then he creates the internet
party which is a new political party in
New Zealand and it kind of gains some
traction and he's doing all of this
while running mega upload well mega
upload gets sued and he actually goes to
jail for the second time he's already
been in jail for a few I think a few
weeks a few months before first hacking
stuff this time he gets locked up for a
longer period of time and when they
arrest him they go to his house in his
compound and they just swarm it SWAT
style and in the house they find all
like 40 cars like the nicest cars you
know like um these fancy Mercedes amg's
um Bugattis all this [__] they find all
this art but they also find a 175
million dollars in cash this guy had
that much money in cash in like a in a
room in his house he's kind of like a
proper gangster I mean he's like a
gangster of the gangster and to give
context mega upload had 50 million
visits a day it was like the seventh
most popular website in the world at one
time it accounted for four percent of
the of total traffic in America and it
had 180 million users and people were
transferring 800 files a second on mega
upload this thing was huge he had and it
was ran almost like a proper company he
had 155 employees you know Engineers
customer service admin all this stuff
and it was wild and this is a wild story
that like I just came across because I
was reading about miss.com his wife or
his ex-wife very fascinating guy this
guy's super prolific he even created
this thing called um a mega car so he
was trying to launch a car company that
was like Internet connected and it
didn't like work out wonderfully but he
built like a handful of the cars but
super prolific very interesting
um
and I thought that you might have a
little bit of stories about this guy
this guy seems like he runs in your
world a little bit I'm gonna send you
this I can't say this on the Pod but uh
We've dm'd before and uh I just have to
show you what's in this DM we can't this
this is not going to be good content but
you you have to see this what what um
was it just like crazy inappropriate
yeah I'll send it to you after this but
um yeah this guy is prolific I feel like
he's kind of like the um
Rogue Mark Andreessen totally like Mark
Andreessen is also surprisingly massive
a prolific internet guy who was like you
know had like a bunch of ideals and like
took took at it Mark Andreessen just
like sort of took more of the straight
path and this guy went rogue that's kind
of how I think about him
um I can't believe I'm blown away by
this Call of Duty thing
yeah like he like like this isn't like a
he said she said thing I mean that this
is like rankings like you can actually
see like leaderboards and he was number
one yeah but does he just have like a
basement of like you know 15 year old
Korean boys that are playing for him or
something like this do I really believe
that this guy was the number one
worldwide Call of Duty player that is
insane that is so crazy that that's like
what's the story about the the Uber guy
Travis where he was the number one Wii
tennis player in the world or something
I think he was like two so basically the
story is like Chris sack of this famous
investor and Travis were like at Chris
saka's like vacation home Chris sacca Mr
Saka was there Travis
well you know that's how we got a D you
know that's how we gotta explain the
story
um so you know the difference between
the two sakas uh so so kind and polite
so Mr Saka and Travis are playing Wii
tennis and Travis crushes the dad Mr
Saka and Travis at the end of the game
goes Mr Saka I've got a confession any
kind of like uh you know what's that
princess best movie with like uh I don't
think the word means what you think it's
a princess diary he kind of like throws
the Wii controller into the right hand
he goes I've been playing left-handed
the whole time but I'm really
right-handed and he just like
obliterates them even more and he goes I
have another confession and he goes to
the the game uh the rankings and he's
like two or three and we tennis uh and
he's like the lift of we tennis
seven out of ten we'll give him
um and so uh yeah this kim.com guy he's
crazy man we got I would love to have
him on the Pod uh he's uh super
interesting
yeah that's a crazy story
um also he I feel like he did he didn't
launch his own crypto token like the
odds of him not doing his own token in
the last five years like that had to be
like a one in one million chance of him
not doing it he probably uh I mean he
was like indicted to talk about it but
yeah he probably had like I bet you he
was like banned for like uh you know
selling securities I bet you he had some
I didn't look into like uh what is what
his band was and what the what the
verdict was but I mean he was in like
legit trouble I mean he was in prison uh
right and so he probably can't
um but what's crazy is number one in
Call of Duty number two that he had 175
million dollars in cash in a room in his
house that's that's wild I don't even
know I would like to know how much like
physical space that takes up but that'd
be a lot
isn't it like always disappointing it's
like that's just two briefcases yeah
dude on The Sopranos I was watching last
night they gave a guy 75 000 and it was
in an envelope like not a like not a
like a manila like not even the type
that you've got to go to FedEx for the
type that you have in your home uh I
can't tell you how disappointed I would
be
like if I ever am involved with any kind
of Ransom or if I win some sort of prize
like I need the giant check if I win a
prize and
if you're gonna give me some cash like
just get it in the smallest bills
possible I want duffel bags I want I
want like a you know a Costco trolley
bringing me the cash like if I get
something and it's in an envelope I
don't care what's inside I'm throwing it
away yeah if it fits in my jacket pocket
I'm out and it like yeah and it was like
the side pocket of like a suit where you
reach in so you know those pockets are
small and they fit in that 75 000
whatever fit in that jacket very yeah
just keep it yeah
um I bought a lottery ticket in Canada I
didn't win by the way you buy lottery
tickets
yeah I so I have this moment whenever I
get up to the counter where my brain
just goes into an instant fantasy of
like and then this was the day and then
I'm telling people that I almost didn't
buy it but I just said hey screw it and
I bought it and I won dude I should ever
I do that at least one out of three
times I'm at a counter in the US they
require cash so that just that's what
saves me from not buying it but um in
Canada you could buy it on your card
it's great we're gonna wrap there
yeah we could we could wrap there all
right that's the Pod we gotta start
saying the gentleman's agreement every
time by the way I keep forgetting to
go subscribe to us on YouTube
that's it
[Music]